hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is that 1080p phone it's the Droid
DNA now when I first came out a couple
of months ago actually I didn't give it
a whole lot of attention and I actually
didn't do any videos on it because I was
so enthralled in the galaxy note 2 but
now that I've come back to and I've
spent a lot more time with it over the
past couple of weeks I've gotten to know
it a lot better and to be honest it's
really worth taking another look at so
without any further ado this is the
Droid DNA revisited so when it was
announced HTC made a big deal about how
this is not a phablet like the Galaxy
Note 2 that I carried and to be honest
they feel completely totally separate
very different devices so HTC is totally
right these are not competing for the
same customers they're not competing in
the same form factor space and having
big hands I tend to use the Galaxy Note
2 of one hand but for most people this
is a two handed device with this for me
it's still a one-handed device so again
they're very very different and they
almost they just feel different in the
hand as well considering that the note 2
is made of all plastic and the Galaxy
Note 2 doesn't feel anything like the
Droid DNA which is all a unibody feel
polycarbonate back very very well sealed
in just if anything the build quality is
one of the most impressive reasons to
get this phone so let's talk about that
build quality shall we this guy is a
beast when it comes to build first of
all it's made of all glass and metal and
on the back it's this polycarbonate
which is I guess a fancy word for
hardened plastic but it feels really
good it's a soft touch back now in the
front as you'll see it's a sort of
curved around the edges here so it feels
like the entire thing is one just sheet
of glass and you never really encounter
any seams and the entire device is
sealed in now that does mean you can't
upgrade the battery or swap out
batteries or use external storage and
you can only access the micro sim by
using that SIM card ejector tool on the
top but other than that it's also then
for good reason and that allows them to
have this sort of a prism shaped look
where they stack the internals inside
the phone in a sort of a pyramid and
that gives them extra space for a larger
battery at2020 milliamp hour battery
I'll get to that in a second and it also
has you know a high-end camera 8
megapixel camera has a Qualcomm
Snapdragon s4 pro inside and all kind of
wrapped into a pretty
compact package but in terms of pure
quality everything about this is
high-end from the power button on the
top to the volume rocker on the side to
the capacitive buttons to the red
speaker grille on the side the metal
ring around the camera on the back all
of this screams quality except the beats
logo on the back that that does not
scream quality at all so overall I'd say
I prefer the design and the build of
this phone to the Galaxy Note 2 now I do
happen to like screen size of the note 2
better but I got to say that this this
next thing I'm about to talk about the
1080p display is the killer feature on
this phone and we all expected that it's
the Droid DNA it's that 1080p phone in
the United States this was the first
iteration and I got to say this is the
best display on any mobile device period
better than the iPhone better than the
note 2 better than the galaxy s3 better
than any other displays available at
least in the United States that you can
get this happens to be on Verizon but if
you want an international version it's
called the J butterfly it's not red and
black but it's also got that 1080p
display and now it's kind of started
this first wave of other 1080p devices
that we're going to see for example the
Sony Xperia Z that I showed you guys
from CES that's a 5-inch 1080p display
the ZTE grand s that's a 5-inch 1080p
display and I'm probably going to go
ahead and put my money saying that the
galaxy s4 is going to be a 5-inch 1080p
display so this is the first one in the
United States that has that so with that
resolution in that size that gives it a
pixel density of 441 PPI
and a lot of people like to say oh
you'll never see the difference between
that and the iPhones Retina display is
this display all that it's cracked up to
be yes it is all that is cracked up to
be and you absolutely can see the
difference watching videos gaming the
overall media experience the preview
when taking pictures with the camera
everything you see on the display is
really really sharp and crisp and also
it happens to be extremely bright I
didn't really realize how dim the AMOLED
displays are in the galaxy s3 and the
note 2 until I took this guy outside and
pumped up the brightness and it looks
like I'm indoors you can see everything
perfectly legibly it's very visible so I
gotta say the brightness was really
impressive viewing angles were also
extremely impressive if you check out
the viewing angles you can pretty much
say that you can read anything from
probably almost 90 degrees on this phone
so
overall this is a great display and it
makes this phone worth buying almost
every category that being said can this
phone push all these pixels well they
also answer to that is yes I didn't
really find any performance hiccups
especially with HTC Sense you know it's
not stock Android but it is Android 4.1
but you know sense kind of does its
thing you know people like HTC Sense
that have been using HTC phones before
this and you'll be used to it you'll
find yourself right at home of use an
HTC phone before performance is pretty
smooth especially the notification bar I
found that that was like extremely fast
really responsive when I was pulling it
down actually more so than the Galaxy
Note 2 but I really did like that the
performance of this phone is pretty fast
it also has a Qualcomm Snapdragon s4 pro
inside so you would expect it to be
pretty good performer you'd also expect
it to have good battery life it doesn't
the droid DNA has a 2020 milliamp hour
battery inside to put that into
perspective the galaxy s3 has a 20 100
million power battery and the galaxy
note 2 has a three thousand one hundred
million power battery so a two thousand
20 million power battery is a lot closer
to the days of the one year old Galaxy
Nexus which had an eighteen hundred
million power so it's not the biggest
battery in the world and you're also
pushing 1080p display and a Snapdragon
s4 pro quad-core 1.5 gigahertz processor
I was charging it at 3 p.m. every day
this is the the worst thing about this
phone as the Droid ena has a terrible
battery life now that doesn't matter for
a lot of people who might find
themselves near a charger all the time
but you got a don't want to recommend
this phone just because the battery life
is so bad if you do have multiple
chargers you can bring them with you
also it doesn't support wireless
charging but it's also sealed in so you
can't replace the battery so you can't
carry a spare battery so it really
depends on having a plug in a charger
wherever you go that's the killer
feature on this phone in the bad way of
killer it's got a terrible battery life
other than that when I come from other
phones like the note 2 and s3 to come to
this phone you notice a lot of the
little things besides the incredibly
great build quality I noticed a lot of
the software features that were
different for example the multitasking
that
they changed is just very bad it take it
takes up a whole entire full screen app
it hides the notification bar but you
can only see one app at a time and you
can only close one app at a time where
with regular Android you can see like
five or six so I don't know why they did
that I hope they can at least adjust
that so you can see more apps with HTC
senses a multi app preview other than
that Beats Audio is some kind of weird
gimmick I had headphones plugged in and
if I turn Beats Audio on it just kind of
turned up the volume a little bit bumped
up the bass a little bit kind of like an
equaliser I also was using bluetooth
headphones with these and I turned Beats
Audio on and it did the same thing so
clearly it's not an internal hardware
thing it's just changing an EQ it's and
they call it Beats Audio add-on in terms
of optimized apps that's a pretty
important thing which apps take
advantage of a 1080p display well
obviously not every app does but apps
that use a lot of text and apps I'd show
a lot of video and images are going to
look awesome things like Flipboard your
Twitter apps your browser's they all
look great so I was using Chrome Beta
and I use a falcon Pro still for Twitter
and those look extremely sharp
especially with the text in the media
previews so I can definitely say that
the app set might not be optimized that
just happened to use a lot of text and
elements and things like that
still look great icons also look great
it doesn't have the same problem as the
Nexus 10 where you know tablet apps are
lacking and it has a 2560 by 1600
display but you'll notice that it does
look a lot sharper when using apps on
the screen but my conclusion on the
Droid DNA is that this is a bit of a
mixed bag it's obviously got a bunch of
great features an awesome display a
great build quality but then it has that
awful battery life that kind of kills
the entire package and you can go ahead
and add this phone to a long list of
devices that have all but awesome specs
for just one thing on the list is bad
for example the Nexus 4 a lot of people
love that phone great budget great build
quality great OS no LTE you know a lot
of people will love the Galaxy Note 2
great you know battery life great
display huge display awesome apps s-pen
features but it's too big so there are a
lot of phones that kind of fall short on
one particular thing this phone's
critical pad thing about it is the
battery life so just know that if you're
going to get into this that's we're
going to have to beware
yeah that being said I've got a video
for you guys that will probably blow you
away coming up next because it's kind of
the daddy of this phone so puts this
phone to shame so stay tuned for that
make sure you subscribe if you haven't
already and click that like button below
if you enjoyed thank you for watching
and I'll catch you guys in the next
video peace
you